you go to Second City and there you meet
you you hit the sweet spot because tell
me who's there when you're there okay so
the first show I saw at Second City I
moved there in the summer of 95. I just
graduated college I didn't know what I
wanted to do but I knew I wanted to go
to a big city that wasn't necessarily
Atlanta you know I just wanted to see
more of the country more of the world I
moved to Chicago so the summer of 95
there was this crazy heat wave in
Chicago and it killed people like 800
people died in Chicago that year so here
I am with my cardboard suitcase
no one to blame yourself
no I get it
so that was my first uh you know Taste
of life in the big city and it was so
hot one of my roommates was saying like
hey you know what there's a comedy
theater downtown uh they do free improv
after their show uh cheap beer and it's
air conditioned I was like sold so I
went to Second City for one of their
free improv sets and I'll never forget
it that was like my you know aha moment
exactly exactly so it would have been I
think Adam McKay John Glazer Kevin Dorff
uh Rachel Dratch Jenna jolovitz and I
think Scott Allman were on stage then
and so that's when I just fell in love
and it really was one of those things
where I was like
this is this is what I do with my
friends just like hanging out
they're doing this for a job this whole
audience is eating them up with a spoon
and so I was like I want to do this so I
signed up for the classes and you know I
would just keep going back to shows I
would see Tina Fey who joined the main
stage taking the place of John Glazer it
was just so fun to see the evolution of
these things and for me like the feather
in my cap you know and of course going
all through all that but
from remembering that point in 1995
to working my way up and then being able
to work with Adam McKay and being able
to work with John Glazer and Rachel
Dratch and Tina Fey and Kevin Dorff and
like all these people who like inspired
me that's pretty cool that's it was fun
and I do not take it for a granted it's
funny because you mentioned all those
people and I think there's I mean
there's a obviously a couple that went
to uh SNL but there's so many people you
mentioned there that ended up being
writers for me performers for me and
just uh realizing you know that that
whole generation of comedic performers
were people that I got to work with and
then you come to New York they were the
bridge that got me the youth yeah you
came to New York and you started doing
stuff for us and then it was really fun
because for years you did bits for us
then you get cast in 30 Rock and you
start coming on as a celebrity which was
you know I mean it was just wrong wait
what um no okay
no no it was just it was really cool to
see that happen for you I'm being it's
no it's no fun when I'm sincere but damn
it it's not as funny I'll get the
sincere [ __ ] out of the way but it was
really nice to see you you were always a
very talented and funny sweet guy and
you did all this great work for us and
then you became Jack McBrayer and we
would have you on as Jack McBrayer and
the crowd would be like oh my god there
he is right when you didn't have to be
dressed as a mule or a spinning wheel or
anything you could have just chose to
yeah exactly
still came on as a mule but that was
your choice
so but you come on and when Tina
approached you to play this page Kenneth
on uh on the show on 30 Rock did you
did you look at the character and just
know exactly how to do it I I did um
which you kind of wrote to you she did
and I don't think that's any Secret at
all but I knew Tina from Chicago's
Second City days uh her husband Jeff
Richmond was my director at Second City
so I was definitely connected to them
and they knew my work
um so when it came time for her to write
the pilot for 30 Rock they did add a
page and I think it was written towards
me I still had to audition and
everything but man I'm glad how did you
prepare for that did you well I knew
that script backwards and forwards
because even though Tina was really
rooting for me you know I still had to
prove myself to all the network the
studio all that kind of thing
um so I got prepared and I don't know if
you know this story do you all know the
story about when I put myself on tape
for the 30 Rock audition um I happen to
be in New York so this would have been
the summer of 2005. and I happened to be
in New York I think for an Improv
Festival Tina got wind that I was in
town so she was like hey I know you're
in town will you stop by the NBC casting
people put yourself on tape for the
Untitled Tina Fey pilot and I was like
uh yeah so I knew because I knew that
she had like kind of tailored it towards
me I needed to crush this I needed to
knock it out of the park so besides
being very prepared like how can I make
the best impression possible you know
I've actually played a page on Conan's
late night show multiple times I wonder
if so I called up y'all's page desk and
I got up there and I taught the Wardrobe
I was like can I borrow just for 20
minutes a page uniform well yeah
whatever so they put me in there your
hair and your makeup people like you
know gussied me up and I went upstairs
to the whatever floor put myself on tape
for the Untitled Tina Fey pilot and that
is the tape that got me through the
studio through the network it got me the
job it got me the job is it fair for me
whatever you're gonna say no you can't
you use my people you use my wardrobe
you use my makeup and see this was
supposed to be a nice story and here you
go
sure I deserve some percentage
I did not know that I did not know that
you had uh stepped on my back too oh she
reached this great height but it
is to it
[Music]
that part and I
remember wait a minute I'm in the early
three rocks I completely forgot yeah
because I remembered Tina coming by to
shoot a part where I think Tracy was on
my show and then Tracy does Conan yeah
and then the sixth episode of the first
season yeah and then she has uh
she I guess we used to go out was the
idea I think I I was uh Tina's uh Liz
lemon's old boyfriend Curry y'all were
supposed to lose your virginity to each
other yes yeah and then which is very
plausible uh and then I did a scene I
remember I had a scene with Alec Baldwin
correct on the show Once and that was
just the very beginning of the show and
then the show took off yeah they did not
meet me anymore
you came back we made many references to
you yes I remember I think Tim Conway's
character had a great reference he was
such a funny joke Tim Conway says
um I saw Conan O'Brien in the hallway
with the guitar because I used to just
walk around 30 Rock with a guitar I
always have a guitar on just nervous
habit so I think Tim Conway's line was
something like I saw Conan O'Brien
uh who is she and why is she so sad
ly I think it was like I saw a tall
lesbian with a guitar who is Conan and
why is she so sorry okay better
that's such a great
so it's all lesbian in the hallway
but it was makes me very happy